alright hey everyone welcome back um so
let's continue our discussion today of
reinforcement learning and mdps
and specifically what I hope you learn
from today is how to apply reinforcement
learning um even to continuous states or
infinite state MVPs so top out
discretization model based RL talked
about models the simulation and fitted
value iteration is the main algorithm I
want to lead up to for today just a
recap because we're going to build on
what we had learned in the last two
lectures wanna make sure that you have
the notation fresh in your mind
MVP was state's actions transition
probabilities discount back to reward
that was an example V PI was the value
function for a policy PI which is
expected payoff if you execute that
policy starting from a status and these
star was the optimal value function and
last time we figured out that if you
know what is V star then Python the
optimal policy or the optimal action for
a given state can be computed as the
augments of that and one one one thing
though we'll come back to later is an
equivalent way of writing that formula
is that this is the expectation with
respect to s Prime
drawn from PS a B star best prime right
so when we go to we've been we have been
working with discrete state MVPs with
the eleven state MVP so this is a sum
over all the states s prime but when we
have will go to continuous state MVPs
the generalization of this or what this
becomes this is the expected value with
respect to s prime drawn from the state
transition probabilities you know with
index by s a current state currents that
action of the value that you attain in
the future so V star of s Prime and
we saw the value iteration algorithm
we're also so we talked about valuation
policy iteration but today we'll build
on value iteration but the value of the
raishin algorithm uses Spellman's
equations which says take the left hand
side set it to the right hand side right
and for V star if V was equal to V stop
the left hand side it's equal to the
right hand side that was um oh I'm sorry
it's missing a max there right so if he
was equal to V star then the left hand
side and the right hand side would be
equal to each other but what value
iteration does is an algorithm that
initializes V of s is 0 and repeatedly
carries his update until the converges
to V Star and after that you can then
compute PI stock or fine for every state
find the optimal action
ok so um because we're going to build on
this notation and this set of ideas
today supposed to make sure all this
makes sense right any questions ok all
right so ok so everything we've done so
far was built on the MDP having a finite
set of states right so with 11 state
MTPs was a discrete set of states um
last time on Monday I think so much she
asked well how do you do of continuous
States so we'll work on that today but
let's say you want to build a right
let's say you want to build a car maybe
a self-driving car right the state space
of a car is let's see I'm gonna well
instead of taking the my artistic side
view of the car if you take a top-down
view of a car alright so this is from
the satellite imagery you know top down
the other car with two wheels of call
having this way how do you model the
state of a car right well calm the way
to model the state of a car that's
driving around the planet earth is that
you need to know the position and so
that can be represented as X comma Y two
numbers to represent you know really
lots your lattice you or something right
you probably want to know the
orientation of the car right may be
measured relative to north
what's the orientation of the car and
then it turns out if you're driving at
very low speeds this is fine but if
you're driving anything other than very
low speeds then will often include in
the state space also the velocities and
angular velocity so X dot is the
velocity in the X direction so X all
this dx/dt right oh this this velocity X
Direction Y dot it's lost in y direction
and theta dot is the angular velocity
the rate at which your car is turning
okay and this sort of um up to you how
you want to model the car is it
important to model the current angle of
the steering view is it important to
model how worn down is your front left
tire I supposed to have worn down is
your beer right tire so depending on the
application you are building is up to
you to decide what is the state base
state space you want to use the model
this car and I guess it and if you're
building a car to race on a racetrack
maybe it is important to model what is
the temperature of the engine and how
you know one down this each of your four
tires separately but for a lot of normal
driving this would be you know
sufficient level of detail to model the
state space but so this is a six
dimensional so this is a six dimensional
state space representation oh and for
those they work in robotics that would
be called the kinematic mode of the car
and that would be the dynamics model car
right if you want to model the
velocities as well
um oh let's see how about the helicopter
all right
the States howdy marvelous taste is a
helicopter helicopter flies around in 3d
rather than drives around in 2d and so
common way to model the statesman's
helicopter would be to model it as
having a position X Y Z and then also a
3d orientation of a helicopter is
usually modeled with three numbers which
we sometimes call the roll pitch and yaw
right so you know if you ever an
airplane row is that you roll into left
or right pictures are you pitching up
and down and you always know are you
facing north south east or west so this
is one way to turn the three-dimensional
orientation of an object like an
airplane or helicopter into CT numbers
so so the details aren't important if
you actually work a helicopter you can
just figure this out but for today's
purposes just right I guess the row
picture but to represent the orientation
of a three-dimensional object flying
around is conventionally represented
with three numbers such as a rotation
jaw and then I thought why don't you see
dot Phi dot theta dot side on the linear
velocity and the angular velocity okay
maybe just one last example so it turns
out in enforcement learning maybe early
early history of reinforcement learning
one of the problems that a lot of people
just happen to work on and and therefore
you see in a lot of reinforcement
learning textbooks there's something
called the inverted pendulum problem but
what that is is a little toy which is a
little cot there's on wheels there's on
a track and you have a little pole that
is attached to this cot and there's a
three swivel there
and so this pole just flops over all
this pose just swings freely and there's
no motor there's no motor at this at
this little hinge there and so the
inverted pendulum problem is see that my
prepared this right is if you have a if
you have a free PO and if this is your
carts moving left and right the inverted
pendulum problem is you know can you
with a swivel can you kind of balance
that right well and so one of the common
textbook examples of reinforced learning
is can you choose actions over time to
move this left and right so as to keep
the pole oriented up with right and so
for a problem like this if you have a
linear wheel just a one-dimensional you
know like a real aircraft that this cart
is on the state space would be X which
is the position of the cot theta which
is the orientation of the pole as well X
dot and theta dot right so this would be
a four dimensional state space for the
inverted pendulum if this like running
left and right on a railway track and
the one dimensional railway track right
um
so for all of these problems if you want
to build you know a self-driving car and
have it do something or build an
autonomous helicopter and have it either
harvest a bleed or flight trajectory or
keep the pole upright and inverted
pendulum these are examples of robotics
problems where you would model the state
space as a continuous state space so
what I want to do today is focus on
problems where the state space is our n
so n dimensional set of real numbers and
in these examples I guess n would be
four or six or twelve right oh and again
for the for the mathematicians in this
class
technically angles are not real numbers
because they wrap around
we go to 360 and then they wrap around
to zero but I think for the purposes of
today that's not important so we're just
treatises RN so um serve the most
straight straightforward way the most
straightforward way to work with a
continuous state space is discretization
where you know you might have in this
example a two dimensional state space
maybe uh
X and theta for the inverted pendulum
and then you just lay down the set of
grid values right and disparate eyes it
back to a discrete state problem and so
you know so you can give the state's a
set of names
one two three four whatever and anywhere
within that little square you just
pretend that you're MDP that you robot
doesn't stay number one so this takes a
Content stay problem and turns it back
to a discrete state problem um
this is such a simple straightforward
way to do it this is actually reasonable
to do for small problems and if you have
a relatively small low dimensional state
Series MVP like an inverted pendulum
problem you're a four dimensional it's
actually perfectly fine to discretize
the state space and solve it this way
let me describe some disadvantages of
discretization first and then and then
which a little bit about when you should
just use discretization because even
though it's not the best algorithm it
works fine for smaller problems but for
bigger problems we'll have to go to more
sophisticated algorithms like fitted
value iteration okay but um so what are
the problems with discretization right
well first
this is a very this is kind of a naive
representation for V star and PI star
right which is you know remember the
very first problem we talked about of
predicting housing prices
imagine if X was the size of a house and
vertical axis was the price of a house
and you had a data set that look like
this discritization is that the
discretization equivalent of trying to
for the function of this data would be
to look at the input feature and you
know let's discretize it into five
values and for each of these little
buckets in each of these five intervals
let's fit a constant function right
something like that so this staircase
would be how you know descritization
will represent the price of a house as a
function of the size and the analogy is
that what we're doing in reinforcement
learning is you want to approximate the
value function and if you were to
discretize it then on the x axis is
maybe the state and now I'm down to one
dimensional state right because that's
what I can plot and you're saying that
well let's approximate the value
function you know as a as a staircase
function as a function of the set of
states right and you know and this is
not terrible if you have a lot of data
and very few input features you can get
away with this this will work okay but
this doesn't it doesn't seem to allow
you to fit a smooth function right so
that's one downside so it's not a very
good representation and the second
downside is the
right someone fancifully named curse of
dimensionality which is Richard bellman
had given this name as a cool sounding
name but what it means is that if the
state spaces in RN and disparate eyes
you know each dimension into K values
then you get paid to the end discrete
states so if this critize position and
orientation into ten values which is
quite small then you end up with you
know ten to ten states which grows
exponentially in dimensional state space
n so this transition works fine if you
have relatively low dimensional problems
like two dimensions no problem four
dimensions maybe it's okay but they were
very high dimensional state spaces this
is this is not a good this is not a good
representation and it turns out the
curse of dimensionality to take a
slightly aside from continuous state
spaces because the dimensionality also
applies for very large discrete state
MDPs
so for example one of the places people
have apply reinforcement learning is in
factory optimization right so if you
have a factory with a hundred machines
in a factory and if every machine in the
factory is doing something slightly
different then if you have a hundred
machines in the giant factory and each
machine can be in K different states
then the total number of states of your
factory is K to the power of 100 right
and so even if so so curse of
dimensionality also applies to very
large discrete state spaces such as if a
factory over hundred machines and then
your total state space becomes kids at
100 and it turns out that for this type
of discrete state space fits a value
iteration
can be a much better album as well we'll
get to Fitz evaluation a little bit okay
so let's see so some practical so now
despite all this criticism of
digitalization if you have a small stage
space is a simple method to try to apply
you know and and if you're if you're
very small so you say go ahead and
discreet eyes they could be one of the
quick things to try and just get
something working so let me share have
you some maybe guidelines this is this
is how I do it I guess right if you have
a you know two dimensional state space
or three dimensional state space is no
problem just discretized usually for a
lot of problems it's just fine if you
have maybe a four to six dimensional
state space you know I would think about
it and it will still often work so for
the inverted pendulum which is four
dimensional state space it works just
fine I've had some friends work on
trying to drive a bicycle right which
you can model the six dimensional state
space and you know disk realization it
kind of works is that it works if you
put some work into it one of the tricks
you want to use as you approach to four
to six dimensional state space range is
choose your discretization more
carefully so for example if the state s2
is really important so if you think the
actions you need to take or the value of
the performance is really sensitive to
state as to and less institute to state
as one then in this range people end up
designing unequal discretization where
you might discretize as too much more
funny than s1 right and then the reason
you do that is the number of states the
number of discrete states is now blowing
up exponentially something the power
power for some of the politics and these
tricks allow you to just reduce a little
bit the number of discrete States you
end up
I think you know if you have a 7/8
dimensional problem that's that's
pushing it that's when I would kind of
be nervous and and you know be
increasingly inclined to not use
dissociation I personally rarely use
this realization for problems that are 8
dimensional and then when your problem
is that you even higher dimensional than
this you know like 9 10 and higher then
I would very seriously consider an
algorithm that does not dispute eyes
it's very very rare to use this code
ization for 4 problems as high even 78
is quite rare I've seen it done in rare
occasions but but and these things get
worse exponentially right with the
number of dimensions so maybe there's a
set of guidelines for when to use the
scores ation it when to seriously
consider doing something else all right
so um in the alternative approach that
you see today what you'll be able to do
is to approximate you start directly
without resorting to descritization and
there'll be an analogy that will make
later just you know alluding to this
plot again right to this analogy between
linear regression when you're trying to
approximate y is function of X and value
iteration when you're trying to learn
their approximate V as a function of s
which is that in linear regression you
say let's approximate X as a linear
function of Y right or if you don't want
to use the raw features Y what you can
do is use you know theta transpose theta
transpose v oh I'm sorry
totally picks up right where Phi of X is
the features of X so if right so this is
what linear regression does where if X
is your housing price then maybe Phi of
X is equal to you know X 1 X 2 X 1
squared X 1 X 2 and so on right so
that's how that's how you can use linear
regression to approximate the price of a
house either as a function of the raw
features or as a function of some you
know slightly more sophisticated study
more complex of the features of the
house and what we what you'll see in
fitted value iteration is a model where
we will approximate Basara ves as a
linear function of features of the state
ok so that's the algorithm wolf build up
to and yeah we're going to try to use
linear regression with a lot of
modifications to approximate the value
function okay and and and again enforce
our learning in value iteration the your
goal is to find a good approximation to
the value function because once you have
that you can then use you know the
equation we had earlier to compute the
optimal action for every state right so
so we just focus on computing the value
function now in order to derive the
fitted value iteration algorithm it
turns out that fits a value duration
works best with a model or the simulator
of D MVP so let me describe what that
means and how you get a model and then
we'll talk about how you can actually
you'll implement the fitted value
generation algorithm and have it work on
these types of problems ok
all right so um what a model or a
simulator of your robot is is is just a
function that takes as input a state
takes as inputs in action and it outputs
the next state s prime drawn from the
state transition probabilities okay and
the way that model is built is that the
states and the actions are both and
let's see and the way the model is built
is the state is just a real value vector
okay oh and um I think for simplicity
but now let's assume that the action
space is discrete it turns out that for
a lot of em DPS the state space can be
very high dimensional and the action
space is much lower dimensional than the
state space so for example for a car you
know s is six dimensional but the space
of actions is just two dimensionals
right the steering and braking it turns
out for a helicopter you know the state
space is twelve dimensional and I guess
you pray most of you I wouldn't expect
you in their heart helicopter flies but
it turns out that you have two four
dimensional actions in the helicopter
the way you find welcomes these are two
control sticks so your left hand the
right hand you know can move has two
dimensions of control and for the
inverted pendulum here's the state space
is for D and the action space is just
one D right you move left or right so
you actually see in a lot of
reinforcement learning problems that
it's quite common for the state space to
be much
dimensional in the action space and so
let's say for now that we do not want to
discretize the state space because it's
your high dimensional but just for the
sake of simplicity let's say we
discretize the action space for now
right which is which is usually much
easier to do but I think as we develop
it evaluation as well well well you you
might you get hints of when maybe you
don't need to discretize the action
space either but let's just say we have
a dispute
dispute action space so all right so how
do you get a model right one way to
build a model is to use a physics
simulator so you know in the case of an
inverted pendulum right it turns out
that well if the action is what's the
acceleration you apply to either a
positive negative or to the to the X all
right so therefore the right then it
turns out that let's see so the state
space is four-dimensional right and it
turns out that if you sort of flip open
the you know physics textbook using
Newtonian mechanics if you know the
weight of the card the way to the pole
yeah I think that says actually you know
the mass of the constant mass in the
pole and the length of the pole it turns
out you can derive equations about what
is the velocity right so it's thought is
equal you know don't don't worry about
this think of the map as declaration
other than something you need to learn
where you know L was the length of the
pole M is the mass of one of these
things as you don't know m is the Hamas
a is the force extender
and so on and and and conventional
physics textbook will kind of let you
derive these equations or rather than
trying to derive this yourself using you
know either yourself using Newtonian
mechanics or finding the help of the
physicist friend there are also a lot of
open source physics simulator software
packages we can download open source
simulator plug in the dimensions and
mass and so on of your system and then
they'll spit out the simulators and
tells you how the state evolves from one
time said to another times then right
and so but so in this example the
simulator will say that s prime is equal
to S Plus you know delta T times I guess
I times s dot where delta T could be
lets say 0.1 seconds right so if you
want to simulate this at 10 Hertz so
that 10 10 10 updates per second so that
the time difference between the current
state in the next day there's one tenth
of a second then you write a simulator
like this okay and but and really the
the most common way to do this is not to
actually derive the physics update
equations the most common way to do this
is to just download one of the open
source physics engines right so um so
this will work okay for problems like
the inverted pendulum I once use a
physics engine to build a simulator for
a four-legged robot and manager user
enforcer learning together for the girl
over to walk around right so it works
the second way to get a model is to
learn it from data
right and I press they end up using this
much more often so um here's what I mean
let's say you want to build a controller
for an autonomous helicopter right so so
this is case study and what I'm
describing is real like this will
actually work right let's do you want to
build up let's say you haven't let's say
you have a helicopter and you want to
build on songs controller for it what
you can do is start your helicopter off
in some state s0 right so with GPS
accelerometers magnetic compass you can
just measure the position and
orientation of the helicopter and then
have a human pilot fly the helicopter
around so the human pilot you know using
control sticks will move the helicopter
they'll know their command the
helicopter with some action a zero and
then a tenth of a second later the
helicopter will get to some slightly
different position and orientation
that's one and then the human pilot you
know will just keep on moving the
control sticks and so you record down
what action they are taking a1 and based
on that how copter will get to some new
state s2 and then they will take some
action a to or get to some state s3 and
so on and let them just write this as
capital T right so in other words what
you do is a take the helicopter out to
the field and hire a human pilot to fly
this thing for a while and record the
position of the helicopter ten times a
second and also record all the actions
that human pilot was taking on the
control stick okay and then do this not
just one time but to do this M time so
let me use a superscript one what you
get the idea
to denote the first trajectory so you do
this a second time and so on and maybe
do this every time
so there's just a lot of map of saying
fly the helicopter around you know M
times right and then recall everything
that happened and now your goal is to
apply supervised learning right to
estimate s T plus 1 as a function of s T
and a T so the job of the model the
jobless simulator is to take as input
the current state and the current option
and tell you where the helicopters gonna
go you know like a 0.1 seconds later and
so given all this data what you can do
is apply a supervised learning algorithm
to predict well what is the next state s
prime as a function of the current state
in action right and the other notation
is when I drew the boxless emulator
above I was using s prime to denote s T
plus 1 and s n right so that's the
mapping between the notations and so if
you use the linear regression version of
this idea you will say this approximate
s T plus 1 as a linear function of the
previous state plus another linear
function of the previous state and it
turns out this actually works ok for
helicopters flying at slow speeds this
is actually not a terrible model about
if your helicopter is moving slowly and
and not flying upside down if you have a
copters flying in the relatively level
way and kind of at slow speeds this
model is not too bad if you find your
helicopter in the highly dynamic
situations find very fast making a very
fast aggressive turn
this is not a great model but this is
that you okay first little speed spiking
um and so I guess a here will be a and
by n matrix because the state space is n
dimensional you know so a is a square
matrix and B will usually be a tall
skinny matrix I guess whereas the
dimension of B is the dimensional state
space by the dimension of the action
space right and so in order to fit the
parameters a and B you would minimize
with respect to the parameters a and B
this so you wanna approximate as
cheapest one as a function of that and
so you know pretty natural to fit the
parameters of this linear model in a way
that minimizes the squared difference
between the left hand side the right
hand side wait did I screw up yes
okay oh sure
what's the difference we find helicopter
M times RS by helicopter once very very
long in this example it makes no
difference yeah this is fine either way
unless some yeah for purposes doesn't
matter sorry
umm for the person since classes doesn't
matter for practical purposes if you
find helicopter M times it turns out the
fuel burns down slowly and so the way to
her coffee changes slowly and you've won
an average over how much fuel do you
have for winning conditions this is what
actually it's done but for the purposes
of understanding without room playing a
single time for a long time you know
well it's just fine as well okay um so
this is the linear regression version of
this and it and we actually talked about
some other models later called lqr in
lqg you you see this linear regression
version of a model as well disree just a
linear model the dynamics right well
we'll come back to linear models
dynamics later next week but it turns
out that if you want to use a nonlinear
model you know plug in a nonlinear you
know if you you can also plug in write
Phi of s you know it may be v prime of a
as well if you want to have a low
nonlinear model and this will work even
better depending on your choice of
features okay now um
finally having run this your little
linear regression thing where you were
and this is not quite linear regression
because a and B are matrices but but you
can minimize this objective but it turns
out - this turns out to be equivalent to
running linear regression n times so s
has 12 dimensions this turns out to
equivalent to running linear regression
n times to predict the first day second
day third state to variable and so on
right that that's this one what this is
equivalent to but having done this you
now have a choice of two possible models
one model would be to just say my model
will said st plus 1 as a st plus b 18 or
another version would be to set st plus
1 equals a cos B T plus epsilon t where
epsilon T is distributed maybe from from
a Gaussian from a Gaussian density okay
and so this first model would be a
deterministic model and this model would
be a stochastic model and if you use a
stochastic model then that's saying that
when you're running your simulator when
you're running in the model every time
you generate st plus 1 you would be
something this epsilon from a Gaussian
vector and adding it to the prediction
of your linear model and and they've
uses stochastic model what that means is
that you know if you similar you have a
calcifying around your simulator will
generate random noise the add and
subtract a little bit to the state space
of the helicopter as if there were
little wind gusts blowing it blowing the
helicopter around okay and this is a
so-so it and in in most cases when
you're building reinforcement learning
models oh and so the the approach we're
taking here this is called model-based
reinforcement learning when you're going
to build a model of your robot and then
let's train the reinforcement learning
algorithm in the simulator and then take
the policy learn and take the policy PI
you learn in simulation and apply it
back on your real robot alright so this
is this dis approach we're taking is
called model-based RL there is an
alternative called model free RL which
is you just run your enforcement
learning algorithm on the robot directly
and that the robot - the robot around
and so on and then I learn I think that
in terms of robotics applications I
think model-based RL has been taking off
faster a lot of the most promising
approaches are model-based RL because of
your physical robot you know you just
can't afford to have a reinforcement
learning algorithm - your robot around
for too long or how many helicopters do
you want to crash before you learn the
armor things as well
model free RL works fine if you want to
play video games because if you're
trying to get a computer or play chess
or thell or go right because you have a
perfect simulator for the video game
which is a video game itself and so your
your your ro algorithm you can on there
blow up hundreds of millions of times in
a video game and
that's fine episode 4 playing video
games were playing on like you know
traditional games model free approaches
can work fine but I most of the a lot of
the successful applications of
reinforced knowledge of robots have been
model based although again the field is
evolving quickly so there's there's very
interesting work at the intersection of
model-based in model free that gets more
complicated but I would say if you want
to use something tried-and-true you know
for robotics problems seriously consider
using model based RL because you can
then fly a helicopter in simulation let
me crash a million times right and no
one's hurt there's no physical damage
anywhere the world is just OK and and oh
and just one last tip one things we
learned building these reinforcer
learning algorithms for a lot of robots
is that you know have you run this model
you might ask well how do I choose the
distribution for this noise right how do
you model the distribution for the noise
once you could do is estimate it from
data but as a practical matter what
happens is so long as you remember to
inject so let's see it turns out if you
used to deterministic simulator a lot of
reinforcement learning our and also
learn a very brittle model that works in
your simulator but doesn't actually work
when you put it into your real robot and
so if you actually look on YouTube or
Twitter in the last year or two there
been a lot of cool looking videos that
people using reinforce learning to
control various really configured robots
a really good snake robot or some five
ago thing or some whatever is this cool
random is I I'm not gonna drink this but
you know if you build a 5 bigger robot I
didn't know what has five legs right how
do you control that it turns out that if
you have a deterministic simulator using
these methods it's not that hard to
generate a cool-looking video of your
reinforcement learning algorithms
supposedly controlling a 5 thing
or some crazy you know a worm with two
legs or something these crazy robots so
you can build in
simulator but it turns out that even
those easy to well not easy even though
you can generate those types of videos
in the deterministic simulator if you
use a deterministic model of a robot and
you ever actually try to build a
physical robot and you take that policy
from your physics simulator to the real
robot the odds of it work on the real
robot
are quite low if you use the
deterministic simulator great because
the problem with simulators is that your
simulators never 100% accurate right
yeah it's always just a little bit off
and one of the lessons we learned the
field the whole few learned applying RL
so a lot of robots is that if you want
your model-based are aware to work not
just in simulation engineer cool video
but you wanted to actually work on a
physical robot like a physical
helicopter that you own that is really
important to add some noise to your
simulator because if the policy you
learn is robust to a slightly stochastic
simulator then the all server
generalizing you know to the to the real
world to the physical real world it's
much higher than if you had a completely
deterministic simulator so I think
whenever I'm building a robot right III
pretty much yeah actually yeah I don't
think I with one exception LKR LQG
without ball next week well one with one
very narrow exception I pretty much
never use deterministic simulators when
welcome to robotic control problems
unless assuming assuming I wanted to
work in the real world as well and and
again you know tips and tricks so the
most important thing is to add some
noise and then sometimes the exact
distribution of noise you know go ahead
and try to pick something realistic but
the exact distribution of noise actually
matters less I want to say then just a
faculty remembering to add some noise
okay
by the way you guys really don't know
this but my PhD thesis was using
reinforcement learning to fly
helicopters so so I'm trying to oh no so
you're talking to someone just crash a
bunch of helicopters and that's model
helicopters and has lived through the
the pain and the joys are seeing this
stuff work or not work all right so now
that you have built a model build a
simulator for your helicopter for your
folding a robot or for your car how do
you how do you approximate the value
function right so um in order to apply
fitted value iteration the first step is
to choose features of the state s right
and then we're approximately of s you
know we're approximately saw using a
function V of s which is going to be
theta transpose Phi of s and so and so
you know in the case of a in the case of
a on inverted pendulum right then Phi of
s maybe you have X x dot maybe one x
squared or x times X dot or x times the
pole orientation and so on so take take
two states as and think of some
nonlinear features
that you think might be useful for
representing the value and remember that
what the value is the value of a state
is your expected payoff from that state
expect some discount or it was so the
value function captures if your robot
starts off in this state you know how
well is it gonna do if it starts here so
when you're designing features pick a
bunch of features that you think help
convey how well is your robot doing
and so maybe for the inverted pendulum
for example if the PO is way over to the
right then maybe the pole will fall over
or give it a reward of minus one when
the pole falls over right but so sorry
I'm overloading notation a bit theta is
both the angle of the pole as was the
parameters but but but if the PO is
falling way over that looks like it's
doing pretty badly
unless X dot is very large and positive
right and so maybe that's interaction
between Phi and X dots you might say
well let me have a new feature which is
the anchor the PO multiplied by the
velocity right because then because it
seems like these two variables cannot
depend on each other so so so just as
when you are trying to predict the price
of a house you would say well what are
the most useful features for the price
of a house you do something similar for
fit evaluation and one nice thing about
one nice thing about maldo based RL is
that one small debasement folsom
learning is that once you have built a
model you see a little bit that you can
collect an essentially infinite amount
of data from your model right and so
with a lot of data you can usually
afford to choose a larger number of
features because you can generate a ton
of data with which to fit this linear
fashion and so you know you are usually
not super constrained in terms of
needing to be really careful not to
choose too many features because of fear
of overfitting you could get so much
data from a simulator that you know you
could usually make up quite a lot of
features
and I saw the features and the not being
useful is okay because you can get an
update from running your simulator for
the algorithm to store for their pretty
good set of parameters data even if you
have a lot of features because you can
have a log that you can generate a lot
of data to fit this function so um let's
talk through the fitted value iteration
algorithm alright you know what this is
a long algorithm let me just use a fresh
board for this alright so let me just
write down the original value iteration
algorithm to speed States so what we had
previously
was we would update BFS according to our
FS plus gamma max over here right so
this is what we had lost Monday and I
said at the start of today's lecture
that you can also write this as this
so let's take that and generalize it to
fit to value iteration
all right um so first let's choose a set
of States randomly unless initializer
Prime's is equal to zero and what we're
going to do is we're so so let's see in
many regression and you learn the
mapping from X to the Y and you have a
discrete set of examples for X and you
fit a function mapping from X to Y so in
what we're going to do here we're going
to learn a mapping from s to V of s and
we are going to take a discrete set of
examples for s and try to figure out
what is V of s for them and then for the
straight line you know to try to model
this relationship right so so just as
you had a finite set of examples a
finite set of houses that you see a
certain set of values of X in your
training set for predicting housing
prices we're going to see you know a
certain set of states and then use that
finite set of examples to use linear
regression into 50 of s right so that's
what this initial sample is meant to do
and so this is the Ultimo's loop of
value iteration a fit evaluation and
then for I equals 1
through em
let's see
all right so what we're going to do is
go over each of these M States for go
over each of these M States and for each
one of them we're going to and for each
one of those days of each one of those
actions we're going to take a sample of
K things in order to estimate that
expected value right
and so this expectation is over s Prime
drawn from the state-transition
distribution it's saying you're from
this state if you take this action where
you get tunics and so these two loops
this for I equals 1 through m and for
each action a this is just looping over
every state in every action and taking K
samples that something K examples of
where you get to if you take an action a
in a certain status right and so and by
taking that K examples and computing
this average QA right is your estimate
of that expectation okay so so all we've
done so far is a take K samples you know
from this distribution of with s prime
is drawn and average V of s OS yeah oh
I'm sorry
and if I move our FS inside sorry then
that's Q of a yeah
sorry there's never just rewrite this to
move our FS inside
so this is written as gamma if you write
this as Matt a little bit a of our s
plus gamma yeah okay yes siree
so move the Max and expectation out then
this is this is Q of a next let's set Y
I equals max over a of Q of a and so by
taking the max over a of Q of a that's
what Y is is your estimate at the right
hand side of value iteration
and so why is your estimate for for this
quantity for the right-hand side of
valuation now in the original value
iteration algorithm I'm just using VI to
approximate out to abbreviate value
elevation in the original algorithm what
we did was we set V of Si to be equal to
Y I write it said you know in the
original value iteration algorithm we
would compute the right-hand side this
purple thing and then said VFS equals to
that he just said right-hand side equal
to set the left-hand side equal the
right-hand side but in fitted value
iteration you know V of s is now
approximated by a linear function so you
can't just go into a linear function and
set the value of points individually so
what we're going to do instead is in
fitted VI
we're going to use linear regression to
make V of si as close as possible to y:i
but VF si is now represented as a linear
function of the state so a linear
function of the features of states so VF
si is Theta transpose Phi of Si and you
want that to be close to Y I and so the
final step is run linear regression to
choose the parameters theta that
minimizes the squared error
oh yes just make my curly braces match
okay
so that's fitted question oh this one oh
this one oh no the M is used differently
the so when we were learning a model M
was just how many times do you fly the
helicopter in order to build a model and
the number of times you find the
helicopter in order to build a physics
model to build a model helicopter
dynamics has it has nothing to do with
this M which is the number of states you
use in order to sort of anchor or in
order to so I think I'm actually so the
the way to think about this is um you
want to learn a mapping from States to B
of s and so the sample you know this M
stays is we're gonna choose M States on
the x-axis right so and that M is the
number of points you choose on the
x-axis and then in each iteration
evaluation we're going to go through
this procedure so you have sort of s 1
up to SM right and then for each of
these you're going to compute some value
Y I using this procedure and then you
fill a straight line to this sample of Y
eyes
think of these think of the way you
build a model and the way you apply
fitted value duration as two completely
separate operations so you can have one
team of 10 engineers fly the helicopter
around you know five helicopter around a
thousand times build them although run
linear regression and they have a model
and then they could publish the model on
the internet and a totally different
team could download their model and do
this and the second team does no need to
talk the first team at all other than
downloading the model off the internet
oh yes a good question you mean there's
something there's something K times
right yep that's a great question yes
that was a yes that was one of my next
points which is the reason you sample
from this distribution is because you
are using so you should do this if
you're using a stochastic simulator
right and then and actually there's
actually also ask you guys what should
you do
how can you simplify this algorithm if
you use a deterministic simulator and
service elastic simulator
let's see so if you said determining if
you said deterministic simulator then
you know given a certain state kind of
such an action it will always map to the
exact same s Prime right so how can you
simplify the yep yes so if your
determines simulator you can set a
equals one and set the sample only once
because this distribution it always
returns the same value so all of these
case ampuls would be exactly the same so
you might as well just do this once
rather than K times this one oh no this
is uh this is actually as square
brackets the thing is we're trying to
approximate this expectation and the way
you're approximate the mean is you know
sample K times if you take the average
right right so so what we've done here
is in alternate approximate dis
expectation
we're going to draw K samples and then
sum over them and divide by K so you
average over the case our polls
let's see so how do you choose em and
how do you test the overfitting so you
know one once you have a model one of
the nice things about model Bizzaro is
let's say that Phi of s right let's say
that Phi of s is 50 features so let's
say you chose 50 features approximately
the value function of your inverted
pendulum system then we know that you
know that you're going to be fitting
linear regression right to this 50
dimensional state space I mean this step
here this is really linear regression
and so you can ask if you want to run
linear regression with 50 parameters how
many examples do you need to fit in
linear regression and I would say you
know if M was maybe 500 right maybe it'd
be ok you have 5 10 examples to fit 50
parameters but if for computational
reasons if it doesn't run too slowly to
even set M equals 1000 or even 5000 then
there's no harm to letting em be bigger
so usually mu must all said to be as big
as you feel like subject to the program
not taking too long to run because it
you know if you're if you're fitting it
unlike supervised learning if you're
fitting data to housing prices you need
to go out and you know collect data
right off Craigslist or was Zillow or
Trulia or Redfern or whatever about
prices of houses and so data is
expensive to collect in the real world
but once you have a model you could set
m equals 5,000 or 10,000 or 100,000 and
just and then your algorithm will run
more slowly but but selassie algorithm
doesn't run too slowly there's no harm
to setting them to be bigger
cool so so I know there's a lot going on
to this algorithm but this is fitted
value iteration and if you do this this
skill you can get reasonable behavior on
a lot of robots by choosing Casella
features and learning the value
functions are approximate the value of
the really approximate expected payoff
of a robot starting off in different
states okay now just a few
details to wrap up again some practical
aspects of how you do this after you've
learned all these parameters this you've
now learned yeah
OSE yes thank you yes so in this
expression where do you get a V of s
prime J from yes so you would get this
from theta transpose Phi of s prime J
using the parameters of theta from the
last iteration of fitted value iteration
just as in value iteration this is the
values from the last iteration the you
use update the new iteration so then you
use the last value of theta is updated
oh and one one one other thing you could
do which is I talked about the linear
regression version of this algorithm
which is you know this hope that this
whole exercise is about generating a
sample of s and Y so you can apply
linear regression to predict the value
of y from the values of s right but
there's nothing in this algorithm that
says you have to use linear regression
in order to now that you've generated
this data set there's this box that
happier this is linear regression right
but you don't have to use linear
regression in Mauldin you know deep
reinforcement learning one of the ways
well one of the ways to go from
reinforce on a deeper enforcer learning
is to just use the neural network for
this step instead then you can call then
then you call that deep reinforcement
learning where no but hey it's legit you
know but but you can also use locally
weighted linear regression or whatever
regression algorithm you want in order
to estimate Y as a function of the state
s yeah and I should have used a neural
network it relieves the need to choose
features PI as well you can feed in the
raw features you know poor angle poor
orientation and use a neural network to
learn them having a supervisor alright
so one last important I guess practical
implementation of detail which is fitted
VI right just approximation to V Star
and this um implicitly defines PI star
right because the definition for pi star
is that
so when you're running a robot you know
you need to execute a policy prior given
the stage music and actually given the
stage Nipigon action and and having
computed v-star it only implicitly
defines the optimal policy PI staff and
so if you're running a rover or if
you're running a robot in real time then
you know actually if you find a
helicopter you might have to choose
control actions at ten Hertz meaning ten
times a second you given the state you
have you choose in action if you're
building a self-driving car again a ten
Hertz controller would be pretty
reasonable guys choose a new action
there maybe ten times a second would be
pretty reasonable but how do you compute
this expectation and this maximization
ten times for a second so in what we use
for fitted value iteration we used
sample of we use K samples to
approximate the expectation but if
you're running this in real time on a
helicopter you know probably you don't
want to at least I don't know for my
robotics implementations I have been
reluctant to use a random number
generator right in the inner loop of how
we control a helicopter it might work
but I but I think you know it's
approximately if you want to compute
this arc Merricks it's approximate
expectation and do you really want to be
running a random number generator on a
helicopter and if you're really unlucky
and a random air engineer generator
journey is an unlucky value.we
helicopter to do something you know iiii
would again just emotionally i don't
feel very good
you yourself driving car has a random
number generator in a loop of house
choosing to drive so just as a practical
matter there are a couple of tricks that
people often use which is the simulator
is often of this form
so most simulators of this form next
state is equal to some function of the
Peter previous state and action plus
some noise and so one thing that is
often done is for your deployment or for
the you know for the for the actual
policy you implement on the robot set
epsilon T equals zero and set K equals
one right and so so just this this is a
reasonable way to make this policy run
on a helicopter which is during training
you do want to add noise to the
simulator because it causes a policy you
learn to be much more robust so little
errors in the simulator your simulator
is always going a little bit off you
know maybe it didn't quite simulate wind
gust or when you turn the helicopter
does it back exactly right amount some
of its as always in practice is always a
little bit off so it's important to have
noise in the simulator in model-based RL
but when you're deploying this in a
physical simulator one thing you could
do to be very reasonable is just get rid
of the noise and stay K equals one and
so what you would do is
let's see whenever you're in the state s
pick the option a according to our masks
over a of V s a so this F is this F from
here so this is the simulator with the
noise removed okay and so what you would
do is actually and and you know
computers are now fast enough you can
you could do this ten times a second
right if you want to control helicopters
self-driving car ten Hertz you can
actually easily do this you know ten
times a second which is your car or your
helicopters in some physical state in
the world so you know what is s and so
you can quickly for every possible
action a that you could take use a
simulator to simulate where your
helicopter will go if you were to take
that action so go ahead and run your
simulator
you know once for each possible action
you could take right computer actually
fast enough to do this in real time and
then for each of the possible next
actions you could get to compute V apply
to that so this is really right as a
prime drawn from PSA but with this term
the six simulator
right so every tenth of a second you
could assimilate to try out every single
possible action user simulator to figure
out where you would go under each every
single possible action and apply your
value function to see of all of these
possible actions which one gets my
helicopter you know in the next one
tenth of a second to the state that
looks best according to the value
function you've learned from fits
evaluation and it turns out if you do
this then you can this is how you
actually implement something that runs
in the whole time and oh and I just
mentioned you know the the idea of a
training was so costly simulator and
then just setting the noise is zero it's
one of those things there's not very
rigorously justified but in practice
this this works well oh yes so so um for
purpose of this you can assume you have
a discretized action space and it turns
out that for a self-driving car is
actually okay to this precise reaction
space for a helicopter we tend not to
disguise the action space but it turns
out if F is a continuous function then
you can use other methods as well right
this is about optimizing over the I
didn't mean to talk about this so sorry
this getting a little bit deeper but
even if a was a continuous thing you can
actually use real time optimization
algorithms to very quickly try to
optimize this function even as a
function of the concerns actually
there's a literature on something called
model predictive control which we can
actually you can actually do these
optimizations in real time and use final
thoughts last question
wait oh say that what's the question is
oh I use an observation yeah yes yes so
you take an action and then your
helicopter do something there'll be some
wind your model may be off and so you
would then a tenth of a second later
take another you know GPS reading
accelerometer reading magnetic compass
reading and use the whole copper sensor
to tell you where you actually are no
cool okay cool all right I hope yeah
hopefully this was helpful I feel like
you know the I think that's fascinating
that the excitement that by myself
driving cars and final hug calls and all
that it gives both down to equations
like these though I think that's not
cool okay that's great thanks I'll see
you guys next week